hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2022 american science fiction and
mystery movie called chariot
this movie is divided into five parts
and revolves around a doctor who
specializes in guiding unwitting
patients through the process of
reincarnation but he finds a rare glitch
on his new patient which has the
potential to irrevocably derail the
patient's future
the movie begins in 1840 when a man
suddenly coughs up blood from his lungs
while chopping wood in the evening he
spots a flashing light from a distant
building and gets confused but he does
nothing and gets into the house
the following day he sees through the
monocular telescope that the light is
still flashing a few moments later the
man passed away but somehow he is
observed by a masked man who wears a
modern suit the scene moves to the
present day where a young man named
harrison hardy consults a sleep doctor
to solve his recurring weird dream that
has been occurring for more than 4 000
times
he states that he has undertaken a lot
of therapies but none of them were
effective
the doctor offers a treatment that he
claims will be very effective to
eliminate the recurring dream
before that the doctor needs to
understand his condition and orders him
to recount the dream
the dream takes place in the house where
harrison grew up he runs down the
hallway to ask his dad about something
but he always awakens before he can even
reach his dad
he adds that he always sees an attic in
the dream but there was no attic in his
previous house and he is very sure about
this at some point after the dream was
driving him crazy he even broke the
ceiling in real life to see whether
there is an attic or not but finds
nothing
turns out that he just moved to
lafayette and rents a room in the old
building the woman asks him whether he
ever heard about the building online and
his responses just make her laugh
after the woman leaves he immediately
goes to bed but is distracted with a
painting
he decides to throw it away and goes to
sleep
as usual the dream occurs again with the
exact same scenario and he wakes up just
before he can see his dad while doing
laundry he accidentally takes the wrong
clothes and a woman named maria suddenly
confronts him
harrison startles for a second and
realizes that the woman looks exactly
the same as the one he saw in his dream
she starts the conversation questioning
his intention to move to lafayette
maria invites him to her place later if
he wants to know more about the place
since harrison has no relatives or
friends in the city later that night he
comes to the woman's place and is
shocked when he sees the painting which
he threw earlier displayed in her room
she claims that the painting has been in
her family for generations
after that they have dinner together
where maria tells him that lafayette
collects unusual people so she asks
harrison what his uniqueness is he
reveals his dream to the woman maria
offers him a cigarette but he refuses
politely and goes to the bathroom
afterwards the pair go on a brief
romantic night and the woman keeps
teasing him until they realize that it's
already late at night before he leaves
maria tells harrison that she had a
dream once and saw a black horse in the
middle of the beach outside her beach
house
she states that she woke up and marched
to the window and it turns out that the
black horse really exists she then
invites him to come over the following
night claiming that she could help him
figure out the attic in his dream
the next day harrison hears a woman
singing from the top of the building and
attempts to approach her however the
masked woman sees him and runs away
he then pays a visit to maria's place
again and tells her about the woman on
the roof earlier
maria reveals that her name is charmagna
and she deliberately wears a mask so
that people don't fall in love with her
as she has a beautiful face
not long after maria starts to tease him
and you know the rest
this time in his dream harrison somehow
glances up at the red string on the
attic which he has never spotted
previously
in the morning harrison meets a man who
recognizes maria's smell and concludes
that he just slept with her
he follows him to his room and enters
his room without harrison's permission
the man randomly shares his life problem
to harrison who doesn't seem to care
about it
he states that he works as a turtle's
caretaker whose job is to force them to
breed he even puts a bed in music in
their tank but none of these efforts are
successful
after the man leaves harrison returns to
the sleep doctor and tells him that the
dream changed a little bit after
sleeping with maria the doctor somehow
knows maria and implicitly states that
she is not a good woman which shocks
harrison he mentions that the timing of
the meeting is not as expected and
suggests harrison should start the
hypnosis treatment at the next meeting
while enjoying his time maria suddenly
comes over to harrison's room with a
camera and tells him about a friend
named rory who is impressed with her
performance as an actress and requests
her to send another recording
she asks for harrison's help to record
her after the recording session maria
invites harrison to her party as
promised harrison attends the party and
maria immediately approaches him while
expressing her happiness she introduces
her friends lauren and oliver to
harrison
he is shocked when lauren and oliver
turn out to live in the same body
maria reveals that lauren shares her
body with a 56 year old oliver when
maria leaves to greet other visitors
harrison tries to talk to the woman with
dissociative identity disorder
he also meets a woman that has two heads
within one body he approaches the d.i.d
woman again but now she has turned into
oliver who is harsh and a bit crazy but
harrison enjoys talking to him
oliver claims that he had seen him in a
photograph shown by a mutual
acquaintance which makes harrison
confused as he never came to the city
previously
on the other side a man named rory is
confronted by mysterious guests who turn
out to be the sleep doctor and a guy
whose face is covered the doctor asks
rory to assist him in some stuff but
rory seems terrified telling him that he
is still experiencing nightmares
the doctor then reveals the other guy
who has the exact face as rory
back to harrison this time he manages to
pull down the red string in the dream
and ascends to the attic but he wakes up
just before he sees what's in the attic
he immediately goes to maria's place but
she is away at that moment he then goes
to the laundry only to find the washing
machines are out of order harrison heads
over to the electrical room but finds
nobody there
he returns to the laundry and is
confused when the washing machines are
working afterwards harrison receives a
brief call from maria who is begging for
help
he calls back and is terrified when the
call is answered by rory's office
receptionist but suddenly he hears
maria's distorted voice repeatedly
saying help me
harrison meets the sleep doctor
he informs him that his dream continues
to expand and he saw old-style polaroid
photos in the attic
the doctor seems panicked and asks him
whether he looks at the photographs or
not harry on states that he recognizes
several people but mostly are strangers
the doctor suggests they start the
treatment immediately
before that harrison questions the
doctor's previous statement about the
timing of him meeting maria but he
refuses to answer and plays dumb
after that the treatment begins
the doctor orders harrison to close his
eyes and gives him a riddle but suddenly
the phone rings he cuts off the wire but
the ringing continues
the doctor somehow refuses to answer the
call and harrison hears maria's voice
again
he immediately runs to his room finding
that the room is completely empty
meanwhile two masked men are standing
outside the building harrison returns to
his room in lauren but in oliver state
shows up
he asks her about maria's whereabouts
but she replies harshly
she pulls out a gun and aims it at
harrison while rephrasing the riddle the
sleep doctor said just now
suddenly lauren intervenes and prevents
oliver from finishing the riddle
harrison grabs a hammer and bravely goes
to rory's office
however he is stopped by the guards and
gets tied up
rory claims that she doesn't know maria
he even says that her acting is bad
afterwards harrison is brought to an
abandoned building where the sleep
doctor has been waiting for him
he is taken to a room where the doctor
finally finishes the riddle the doctor
wears a mask and puts harrison to sleep
in his dream harrison gets into the
attic and finds the doctor there he
reveals that the system is almost
perfect but there was a rare glitch
after harrison met maria who turns out
to be harrison's lover in his previous
life and the doctor has to clean
everything up thus he burns all the
photographs
the scene moves to a couple who come to
their friend's house to have dinner
together
however the woman startles when she sees
another woman upstairs
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching